Don't say I didn't warn you,...
...but this next Kardashian story might make you a little queasy...
...and not for all the normal reasons.
On the latest episode of Kourtney and Kim Take Miami,...
...Kim decides to get a "vampire facial" and document it for all her viewers.
Hey guys, I'm Kristina Behr with Buzz60.
So, what is that on her face?
Basically, doctors take a giant needle, stick it in your arm,...
...spin the blood around in a machine to remove platelets,...
...and then that blood is splattered on your face using little acupuncture-like needles.
She was aiming to look more youthful and smooth out wrinkles,...
...but if anything, she looks more like something out of a horror movie.
You think my skin looks better?
No.
After the treatment, Kim vowed she's never gonna get a face-lift because of the pain.
Though this procedure usually only lasts for about 15 months,...
...it's about 1500 bucks per session.
I'm not sure what could be worse,...
...this True Blood procedure or getting a bird poop facial.
It proves celebs will do just about anything to stay looking young.
Buzz60.
Now you know, pass it on.